[Musique]
mes chers amis mes chers amis de toutes
générations cher christian jacob le film
que nous venons de voir nous crée des
devoirs vis-à-vis de la france et nous
sommes tous des enfants de cette france
là depuis le fond de notre histoire
jusqu'à aujourd'hui croyez moi avec le
député les sénateurs le parlementaire
européen avec le président du conseil
départemental pierre bédier nous sommes
très heureux que depuis hier vous soyez
dans notre département des yvelines
nous avons la chance de travailler tous
ensemble je recommence je voulais
simplement vous dire que le film que
nous avons vu nous crée des devoirs des
devoirs vis-à-vis de notre pays
vis-à-vis de la france et que nous
étions heureux ici les parlementaires du
département parlementaires européens et
élus de vous accueillir avec les jeunes
des yvelines car nous avons un symbole
dans les yvelines le plus jeunes maires
d'île de france appartient à la famille
des républicains
jean prat bac de keating mère du
perray-en-yvelines qui a renversé 30 ans
de socialisme
cher christian jacob pour ceux qui
doutaient de la capacité de notre
famille a mobilisé voilà aujourd'hui une
belle démonstration pour ceux qui
dissertait sur notre rentrée dispersé
voilà une démonstration de rassemblement
oui merci au nom de tous
merci au nom de tous les militants de
tous les sympathisants de tous les élus
à christian jacob
pour cette rentrée à port-marly votre
présence votre nom votre enthousiasme
c'est ce que nous partageons ces vrais
cher françois baroin qu'ils sont
l'avenir et que nous avons un devoir
vis-à-vis d'eux il ne suffit pas de dire
qu'ils sont l'avenir il faut bâtir
l'avenir avec vous
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes vous êtes à le port marly le
port marly alexandre dumas le comte de
monte cristo et il formule apocryphe
qu'il faudra méditer pour les mois qui
viennent tous pour un un pour tous
faisons le ferment de monte cristo ici à
louveciennes à la limite de port marly
mes chers amis où ainsi plus de trois
ans que le président de la république a
été élu que sa majorité gouverne la
france et je cherche ce qu'à ce jour
nous pouvons retenir du bilan de
l'action gouvernementale
en fait peu de choses et j'en suis le
premier désolé car c'est de la france
dont il s'agit je vous le dis la crise
sanitaire n'est en rien responsable de
cet échec car la situation de notre pays
avant crise sanitaire était déjà très
préoccupante
le déficit de l'état voisine et 100
milliards d'euros
certes nous ferons plus de 260 milliards
à la fin de l'année la dépense publique
n'a jamais cessé de progresser la
fiscalité la fiscalité demeure
confiscatoire la trajectoire budgétaire
très éloignés des règles européennes
le rééquilibrage des comptes avant
février 2020 était déjà hors de portée
pour 2022
oui que reste-t-il des belles promesses
de 2017 et de ce nouveau monde qui
devait transformer notre quotidien
corrigé nos nouvelles mono mauvaise
habitude nous débarrasser des archaïsmes
de notre société
secouer nos certitudes bouleverser nos
institutions
oui que reste-t-il que reste-t-il
du président réformateur du président
rassembleur du président censé rétablir
l'autorité de l'état
oui que reste-t-il de tout cela en
vérité le pays n'a jamais été aussi
fracturé ce que j'ai des nommés dans un
rapport à la france d'à-côté
malheureusement elle a gagné du terrain
la communauté nationale est profondément
fissuré après la crise des gilets jaunes
le refus de l'autorité les violences qui
en découlent
la multiplication des zones de non droit
la montée des communautarismes la
gestion erratique
souvenons nous de mars avril jusqu'à
mimer de la crise sanitaire a fini
d'installer le climat de défiance qui
submerge aujourd'hui notre pays est dans
ces deux crises si nous n'avions pas eu
les maires de france pour tenir la
république
où en serions nous aujourd'hui de la
en vérité sa famille ses trois années
révèle l'échec d'une méthode de
gouvernance celle de la verticalité du
pouvoir celle de la recentralisation qui
n'a pas commencé je le dis il y a trois
ans les décisions je sais je sais que
nos compatriotes veulent que ça change
et ce changement là c'est nous qui
devons l'incarner mes chers amis je ne
me suis jamais résignés à accepter le
système qu'on a voulu nous imposer un
système binaire où le choix serait
simple d'un côté la république en marche
de l'autre le rassemblement national
souvenez de ce piège nous avons failli
tomber au mois de juin de l'année
dernière
nous sommes aux antipodes des idées du
rassemblement national et certains
voudraient vous souhaiterez sans aucune
malice paraît-il entretenir l'idée que
finalement le président de la république
serait de droite et aurait choisi un
gouvernement qui construit qui
conduirait une politique de droite bien
mes amis
moi qui suis plutôt le symbole de la
modération sur les mêmes la rondeur je
pense le contraire
qu'importe les mots la politique qui est
menée aujourd'hui n'est pas la nôtre est
cher françois tu l'a démontré ce matin
damien abad et bruno retailleau l'ont
clairement démontrée nous restons un
pays dans lequel la fiscalité est
insupportable parce qu'elle lui à la
fois la compétitivité des entreprises à
l'esprit d'entreprise et à la
responsabilité
nous dépensons mal nous ne travaillons
pas assez il n'y a pas que le temps de
travail
au fond nous sommes en train d'installer
l'idéologie de la décroissance ce qui
est strictement inacceptable la
transition écologique qui est
indispensable ne doit pas être
idéologique et sectaire
elle ne voit pas encore plus fracturées
la france les métropoles et la france
rurale les urbains et les ruraux
l'expérience de l'automne 2010 8 ou une
france s'est rendu sur les ronds-points
parce qu'elle ne comprenait pas une
politique qui d'ailleurs n'était pas
destiné dans ces prélèvements à la
transition écologique mais tout
simplement renflouer un budget sur
lequel on n'avait pas le courage de
faire les économies des dépenses qui
étaient nécessaires
mes chers amis
pardonnez moi de faire référence à des
élus ce que me disait le président des
maires du nord
ce que m'a dit un certain président de
région sud dans une coque d' avance et
je cite ce président des maires du nord
l'écologie punitive venu d'en haut
divise l'écologie qui part du local
rassemble alors je vous le dis puisque
hier vous avez accueilli valérie
pécresse et je m'en réjouis
ger christian jacob est bien ici nous
pouvons conjuguer en ile-de-france une
transition écologique et une politique
de croissance c'est ça l'objectif
au moment où nous nous fixons le choix
des idées
mais le président qui devait restaurer
l'état de droit où on est tous l'ordre
républicain doit être rétablie partout
et pour tous il n'y a pas de démocratie
sans respect de l'autorité
le refus de l'autorité a pris une
dimension nouvelle
accompagnée d'actes de violence nous
avait tous en tête
dijon grenoble paris impuissance de
l'état impunité des délinquants je vous
le dis il n'y a pas de sentiment
d'insécurité
il y à une réalité très concrète de
l'insécurité
certains nous accusent jeter l'huile sur
le feu de faire de l'insécurité un
argument de campagne bien mes amis
demandé aux habitants des territoires
perdus de la république demandé aux
habitants de nîmes où j'étais hier soir
de fontanès tout près d'alès où j'étais
hier après midi
si c'est simplement un sentiment la
sécurité ou une réalité qui pourrit leur
vie au quotidien et bien là dessus nous
devrons être clair intraitable dans le
respect des valeurs de la république
nous devons restaurer l'état d'euros
nous ne trouvons pas non plus accepter
que la présomption d'innocence qui font
notre droit soient systématiquement
bafoués alors ne pouvons pas non plus
limité notre projet politique où seules
questions de sécurité de transition
écologique
nous devons relever le défi d'un pays
dont la croissance économique est
négative dans lequel le chômage va
repartir avec au quotidien c'est aussi
la préoccupation de nos concitoyens oui
je vous le dis comme je le ressens et
pas simplement parce que je suis par la
confiance de mes collègues le président
du sénat je pense que la relance le
redressement de ce pays ne pourra
essentiellement se passer que par le
levier des territoires et que si nous
n'utilisons pas le levier des
territoires si nous continuerons à avoir
cette politique centralisée verticale du
haut vers le bas
vous pourrez annoncé tous les centaines
de milliards de la terre ces crédits ne
seront pas consommer et en même temps on
n'atteindra pas l'objectif du
redressement de notre pays voilà
pourquoi nous nous battons pour cette
nouvelle génération de la
décentralisation
voilà pourquoi nous nous battons pour
une conception de l'état déconcentré au
niveau des territoires
voilà pourquoi nous nous battons pour
que la cellule de base de la démocratie
soit le point de départ du redressement
de se payer quelle que soit la commune
chère rachida depuis la commune de paris
jusqu'à la plus modeste commune de ce
pays
c'est à partir du territoire que nous
pouvons bâtir le redressement
vous savez tout à l'heure nous évoquions
la question ce matin du communautarisme
de la laïcité
hier le président de la république fait
mémoire des 150 ans de la république la
république
elle s'est construit autour de quatre
grands textes sous la iiième l'école la
commune le pouvoir délibératif la loi de
1901 qui permet aux citoyens de
s'associer et de prendre en main une
partie de leur destin et la loi de 1905
qui fondent le principe de laïcité
faisons en outre faisons nôtres en 2020
ces mots d'aristide briand jamais ses
mots de doivent être oubliées
que disait-il
la loi doit protéger la foi temps que la
foire n'entend pas dicter la loi est
bien bien plus que les mots de
séparatisme c'est autour de ces
principes que nous devons conjuguer la
communauté nationale au singulier dans
le respect de chacun que chacune dans le
respect des convictions dans le droit de
croire ou de ne pas croire mais un seul
principe la république et les lois de la
république
je vous le dis comme je le ressens nous
sommes dans la semaine du procès des
attentats de 2015 et moi je vous dis tu
sais choqué la couverture de charlie
hebdo a été pour moi un acte de courage
et de liberté qui les adorent
[Applaudissements]
alors alors que cette rentrée se
présente avec de grandes difficultés
pour d'autres économies et aussi pour
nombre de nos concitoyens
tout le monde le dit mais je pense quand
même assez jeunes qui arrivent sur le
marché du travail
jamais dans les permanences
parlementaires nous n'avons vu autant de
jeunes nous demandant qu'y un stage qui
une alternance qui de les aider dans une
démarche vers l'emploi
peut-on encore croire que le programme
de réformes dont a besoin notre pays
puisse être engagée je crains que nous
alors le moule dit il faudra sans doute
attendre le prochain quinquennat le 27
septembre à la suite des élections
municipales qui ont été un succès
dans notre famille politique et nos amis
alliés du centre
eh bien j'espère que les délégués
sénatoriaux confirmeront le choix qui a
été fait en mars et en juin
vous savez le sénat c'est un espace de
respiration qui tient bon je pense que
nous l'avons démontré et je le dis parce
que je voudrais le remercier devant
bruno retailleau et qui tient bon quand
l'essentiel est en cause mais maintenant
il faut gagner il faut gagner les
élections départementales
il faut gagner les élections régionales
nous avons des présidents qui ont des
bons bilans quelles qu'aient été les
parcours des uns et des autres tous
devront fort de ce bilan les soutenir
partager avec eux montré que les
républicains c'est d'abord la première
force politique territoriale de ce pays
ça doit être votre priorité pour les
mois qui viennent
je vous le dis en ces temps où jamais la
défiance n'a été aussi grande
quels sont les élus qui conserve le la
confiance des français quels qu'aient pu
être les difficultés des municipales ce
printemps c'est d'abord les élus locaux
nous devons être des rebâtissent heures
des reconstructeurs de la confiance
alors bien sûr chacun a en tête
chacun a en tête que nous occupons avec
nos amis du centre le seul espace
politique crédible d'une alternance cet
espace politique cette force
territoriales il faudra l'incarner quand
le temps sera venu
et sans reprendre la fontaine le temps
va venir
chacun doit en mesurer les enjeux et
agir en responsabilité je vous le dis
nous avons un devoir d'unité une fois
exprimer la diversité
il nous fera donc trouver un système au
delà des frontières des partis pour
choisir et soutenir le candidat à
l'élection présidentielle qui semblera
porter nos valeurs
voilà pourquoi j'ai évoqué quelles que
soient les analyses des uns et des
autres cette méthode de départage il
faudra que nous y réfléchissions
tranquillement sereinement pas
simplement au détour d'un grand
interview mais en dialoguant entre nous
et ce sera sans doute mon rôle mon rôle
de président du sénat de m'appliquer le
vieux principe du lièvre et de la tortue
il marchait d'un pas de sénateur qui je
vous le rappelle qui je vous le rappelle
dans cette fable est pas du tout le pas
de l'arthrose mais le pas de la sagesse
et de la paix et je vous le dis
je vous le dis clairement je ne
laisserai pas où ce sera sans moi faire
n'importe quoi car nous avons un devoir
vis-à-vis de la france
nous l'avons entendu de jacques chirac
nous l'avons entendu du général de
gaulle
nous l'avons entendu de georges pompidou
et nous l'avons entendu de la part de
nicolas sarkozy
je vous le dis il ya bien sûr quelques
délices parfois s'exprimer les uns les
autres
mais il ya un tel bonheur un moment à se
rassembler pour proposer un prêt hop au
pays un projet un projet porté par une
femme ou par un homme tu dois incarner
l'avenir de notre pays
[Applaudissements]
alors je vous le dis nous sommes dans
l'université d'été du jeune j'aurais
vraiment les remercier d'être venus
aussi nombreux et leur dire que c'est
vrai que c'est eux qui portent l'avenir
et que s'engager dans la vie politique
aujourd'hui c'était paraît-il pas mode
vous démontrer le contraire
moi j'ai un point commun avec un certain
nombre de ce que vous avez vu sur le
film et avec d'autres ici je pense que
la politique peut changer le cours des
choses et qu'elle doit changer le cours
des choses et que sont la politique
pardonnez moi nous serons alors les
passagers clandestins de la
transformation d'une société qui entre
lobby réseaux sociaux et pensée
dominante nous échappera et c'est la
démocratie qui nous échappera vous avez
donc vous avez donc vous les jeunes
particulièrement est sans doute à nous
dire qu'on doit aller à l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est la france c'est
l'intérêt de la france et des français
l'essentiel cent cinquante ans et un
jour après c'est la république pour que
vive la république
et comme il la france
[Applaudissements]